المتاحف غرضها ان تكون تمنح فرصه للزائر
ان يتعرف بصوره مرتبه وعلميه ومشوقه الى
هذه الحضارات وتحسر وتاوه عند هذه النقطه
ههه نريد
ان المتحف والمسرح الذي تقام عليه قطعه
اثريه مهما مهما جبت لكم بارسل والممثلين
حتى يقوموا بدورهم اذا لم تضع المسرح تقام
فيه المسرحيه فلن يقامن فلن يكون اي معنى
للمسرح اذا ما بنيت المدرسه حتى تعلم فيها
الطالب وتعلم فيها الطالب فلا معنى
للدراسه اذا ما بنيت المستشفى تعالج فيها
طبيب فما لا فلا معنى الحقيقه يموتون
المرضى ولم تجب منكانا لتعالج فيه انا ارى
انه المتحف ومسرح اثار هو المكان الذي
توضع فيه الاثار مما يؤسف له طبعا بطبيعه
الحال لانه في سنوات الاخيره تم بفصل
المتاحف عن الاثار وهذا في تصور الشخصي
خطا كبير ارجو اتمنى من المسؤولين في
وزاره الثقافه تدارك لا يعني هذا باننا
نترك المتاحف الاخرى ذات ذات الاهتمام غير
اثار نتركها ونقول ان داعي لا بالعكس نحن
نريد ان تكون هيئه المتاحف هيئه المتاحف
مسؤوله مباشره عن كل ما له علاقه كل ما له
ليس له علاقه بالاثار يعني الفنون على
سبيل المثال المحليه ال- ال- الفضاء
السيارات وتطورها كل ما كل شيء هذه كنت هي
تابعه لها لكن الاثار المتاحه في الاثريه
يجب ان تكون تحته تحت نطاق وتحت مظله
الاثار لان هي هو مسرحها انا لما الاثار
لما يروح ينقب ويطلع القطع الاثري اين
يذهب بها لازم يذهب بها الى المدح بعد
الترميد
ترى انه المفروض يتم نقلها الى مكان مخصص
الحقيقه
بالكثير من المعلومات بكثير من الاشياء
التي تعطي الراقي في معرفه شيء عن
يسموديين بطريقه مباشره يعني كل ما تجد عن
خطوط الثموديه تجد في هذه الصخره بشكل
غريب جدا الحقيقه كانه السمودي الحائلي
قال لاعضاء التدريس في العالم العربي
انظروا هذه اللوحه مدرسوها لطلابكم هذه
تغنيكم عن ثلاثه اربعه كتب او وراء اربع
صفحات لذلك انا ارى الحقيقه لان ودي يعود
المتاحف واهميه الحقيقه اعاده النظر بانه
يجب فصل
المتاحف الاثريه واي عاداتها الى الاثار
لان الاثار لا توضع في المخازن الا
للدراسه او للترمين لكنه يجب ان توضع في
المتاحف وهذا الفصل بين هذين القطاعين مع
تقديري وكامل احترامي لمن يتخذ هذا القرار
هذا شيء يؤدي الى تاخر ان نبرز الانجازات
الحضاريه للناس لانه هاتين هاتين مختلفتين
هاتان يعني
الله الله هيئه الاثار وهيئه المتاحف
وتتصاد يعني تتصاد امانه يعني في تصادم
بينها بين بينهما لمصالحهم هذا الخاصه
فلذلك ارى الحقيقه يعني ضروره اعاده هذا
المسرح الى الاثار الاثرين لانه لو رحنا
الى المتاحف الاقليميه التي بنيت في عهد
الدكتور عبد الله المصري الله يذكره
بالخير ويمسيه بالخير ادى الدوره هذه
لانها كانت حافضا ليست مخزنه ولكنها كانت
الحقيقه مرئات لاثار كل منطقه موجوده ان
هذا يعود مره اخرى لانه نفرط بهذا النجاح
ثم نعود الناس تتقدم الى الامام لا ترجع
الى الوراء نحن مع الاسف يعني لا اقول
رجعنا الى الوراء ولكننا خلقنا مشكله
يفترض ان لا تخلق طيب هذه نقطه مهمه انا
احببت انه تاخذ وقت تكفيه لان فعلا همم
يعني همم راعي من رجل متخصص لكن حول
المتاحف ثم انطلق
قريبا منه المتحف اللي اذا فتح للببلك
للزوار للعامه
وللمتذوقين يرتقي بثقافتهم جدي هل الكلام
اللي نقوله على الطاوله هذا هو يروح
يشوفوا راي العين يمكن الناس ما تطيق سماء
الكلام بس لما يروح من شرائح عمريه مختلفه
وشرائح ذهنيه مختلفه يجد هالكلام اللي
نقوله مثلا نقش لاتيني يوناني
جلب من من العلا خلاص قدام عيني يمكن يلبس
تنظير يعني في الموضوع هذا
المتحف يا سيدي هو في الواقع تثقيفي تربوي
تعليمي يعني همم
تربوي يربي الانسان ليدخل اليه لانك انت
تشوف الحضارات هذه كلها وتشوف هذه الاشياء
كيف ادت ايه تتربى من خلالها يرتقي فكرك
هذا اذا اعطي المتاحف لمن يستطيع ان
يديرها لكن اذا اعطي للناس لا يستطيع ان
يديره
اثارنا نحن في الجزيره العربيه لما اقول
الجزيره العربيه اقصد حتى اليمن والبلدان
الخليج والاخره هذه ارضنا كلها ارضيه
واحده كم اللي موجود منها خارج خارج
الجزيره العربيه في المتاحف الاجنبيه
صعب اني اقول لك لكن عادات كبيره جدا
كثير
لكن يفترض فينا نحن في العالم العربي سواء
كان من اليمن او من دول الخليج العربي او
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان ابني
متاحفنا بانفسنا وان تكون متاحف ان
التثقيفيه تنوريه تعليميه كل شيء ليش لان
ولا يجب ان نحصرها فقط في اثارها يجب ان
يجب لا تقل متحف الوطني في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
يجب ان يدخل ال- ال- المواطن وغير المواطن
لهذا المتحف ويرى حضاره
على فقط
الاثار السعوديه اثار في الجزء العربيه